five
okay hi everyone who's joining us uh
we are about to do a deep dive into
trees
we are talking about the upcoming trees
functionality for
language so
let's begin at the beginning um
should i open this guide page or should
we look at the the examples here of
tree construction and so on
so the we had a look at these on
on our last meeting and we wanted to
here compare to the old design so you
complained that we had changed a few
things and you wanted to understand
better
the changes we had implemented okay
so yes we can have a look at this and
then go to the comparison section if you
want
well okay let's let's look at comparison
right so there is this this section
difference with the original design
and so we have analyzed
yep and the main difference is that we
have not yet implemented three elements
but it's planned to be implemented on
top of the
new framework based on the data
structure
so most of the things here are about the
details which
we didn't sort out completely the
previous time
on things like inheritance options etc
okay fine all right let me let me bring
up the trees
um um
[Music]
what is it called trees new yes
it's really weird
um could somebody report that my open
guide page mechanism
is opening just a completely wacky
direction yeah i can report it
just to roger yeah cool
at least in the 12 um three prototype
build that might be different
okay yeah okay
all right so this gives us a sense of
what's here
so let's remind ourselves
okay so
tree element we believe in
data subtrees options right right
yep okay okay
and so there's a link to the ref page
for tree element
okay um okay so now question
is there an outer wrapper of tree around
the whole thing or not
or is it just a tree element all the way
down
so our current idea is that the outer
wrapper is actually three element
and internally it's manipulating a data
structure so we will convert as needed
for efficiency i'm sorry i missed
the my question is maybe we should just
call tree element tree
since every sub tree is a tree
is there any difference between the big
tree and the sub trees
not really in in input we can construct
nested trees as planned
and then internalities will get
converted into a data structure
and if the user wants to output the
input form
or do pattern matching things with the
things we discussed recently
then it will be serialized to an sd3s
right i mean
it's really not obvious to me that we
shouldn't just say
you know that we shouldn't just have
tree
i mean i think the previous time we were
just following the
design of text element xml elements
things like that
right no i agree i agree but i think i
think we didn't have the boldness to
want to just call it tree
um
okay hold on one second
um i'm just going to make those sw notes
of 6.
okay so the possibility is a pure tree
whose sub trees are themselves trees
and so this would then be tree hmm
data sub trees it's not completely crazy
okay next question when i get a tree
okay it's a graph
right it's treated as a it's it's a
purple outlined graph object is that
correct
yes correlates okay
do we think it will eventually be a tree
object distinct from a graph object
no so it it is not giving a graph
that's not what we want for tree element
well what do we want we want it to have
head tree element
i thought no i'm not asking that
question right look at this display
right when i click it it has a purple
border
a purple border is the graph border
right
and so for example i can give graph
options to this presumably
do you understand what i'm saying yes
yes i think we are doing this just
temporarily because we don't have an
alternative
okay okay so one of the things we need
to decide is
from a ui point of view what does it
look like
you know presumably we have some kind of
other border here
there's a tree border okay
and presumably tree can take graph of
options yes or no i would think yes
many of the graph options maybe not all
of them am i making sense
right so so options is one of the things
we want to discuss
today and of course we have we are
planning a converter
a graph i think that's good
i think that's good yeah i mean i think
most of the time
people will not be looking inside the
tree object
probably exactly
which possibly makes it see i think
it'll be nice
if you have a tree here's my tree and i
can now say
you know re-option the thing like this
just like i do with graph all the time
okay and i would assume do we need tree
graph and graph tree or do we just want
it to be the case that graph
of tree turns it into a graph and tree
of graph turns it into a tree
potentially there are things to control
in the process because for example
how do you choose the root node
and trees can have several nodes
with with the same payload while graph
cannot
so it's not i see well i think those
things should work
but i agree with you we might want finer
control exactly
okay okay
all right the the the problem of options
and type setting
is important here because graph is a
monolithic thing which everything is
controlled from the top
level but what happens when we nest lots
of
trees each one having its own opinion of
time
type setting
this is do you know what i mean i
understand i understand what you mean um
i mean i can see an argument
to the big tree the enveloping tree
sort of imposes itself on everything
and i can see the argument that the sub
trees can be their own
thing it's somehow
it's i'm i i i have
uh i'm thinking of patriarchal societies
so to speak where the grand
you know the grand grand grandparent
imposes themselves on all future
generations
never mind i mean you know you get the
the the question is do we want to work
down like that or does the
do we want to allow the um um
uh um
um what am i saying uh
uh do do we want to allow the children
to have their own opinion about things
so to speak
um you know sandra on the live stream
suggests a dark green border because
trees are green that's a cute idea
that is a cute idea using green as a
theming color for these things
um okay
okay so where should i look here so
this is tree element we agree i think it
should probably be tree
okay since among other things if i take
a sub-tree of a tree
i still get a tree right so why
yeah i think it's the right thing now
an interesting question see with a graph
a note of a graph could be a graph
but in general a note of a graph isn't a
graph
anyway okay that's my current opinion is
that a tree it should just be tree
okay what are you saying here wrapper
around the tree or directed
tree data structure
yes so we're explaining that our current
view of what three or three element is
look i think trees should have an opaque
set of things inside it
but i think it should be as if you know
it should respond to part and this and
that and the other
the way that it should if it was not
having some compiled opaque thing inside
does that make sense so our plan would
be to make
um three atomic and then we can do
whatever we want with part
yeah i think it's fine in a semantic way
yeah i think that's fine
yeah but um i have no problem with that
and but i think again patterns
everything should be as if
right okay so you know the whole story
is it's
as if
by the way is it obvious that this is
the right way around data first then
subtrees
yes it's obvious because then the leaf
then the
leaf um
right data if any because it might be an
empty
it might just be a an intermediate node
yeah the children might be optional but
the payload isn't
no the payload might be optional as well
the only payload
you know the parent only exists for
their children
right you see what i'm saying
there's nothing like this is a perfectly
reasonable possibility where that's a
a you know that has where there is no
there's none
there's no payload here
right yes yes we have discussed
what's the meaning so what should we put
there to make it empty
i'm not sure that's empty list perhaps
not personal
perhaps nothing nothing
i'm not sure about nothing because it it
nothing is kind of
prepared for lists kernel
all right okay fine although
we have to think about okay fine but
that that means
a pure tree with no
i mean null also has the feature that
doesn't print which isn't a good thing
exactly all right then the leaf of the
tree
is now why is that i see the
what happens if the sub tree is not a
tree object why doesn't that represent a
leaf
i mean why can't i just say null and
then i could just say
you know hello and then you know this or
whatever
right why isn't that go ahead i think
that's fine
like as if you had tree of hello
commentary of hello
but it isn't tree of hello it's it's
tree no that's a different thing
because if i say this represents
a structure like this right
if i put in if if that hello
was a tree now
hello that's another level of tree
yes but what what ian was saying is that
having hello and three hello
would be formally equivalent because
everything is a note
each note is a tree potentially with
children
i don't understand what you're saying i
mean this is a different structure this
one here and this one here
so i'm not saying tree of null coma
hello i'm saying tree of hello
comma none or empty list
like you would be a tree i see i see
hello
i see i see i see so i'm sorry i got it
the wrong way round
yes okay so this thing here
that seems like a really kind of a weird
thing right
in other words this here tree of hello
common null
i don't understand why we don't flip the
argument order around
and say tree of its sub-trees which it
always has
and if it has something at that node
it's data
because otherwise you can just represent
the
the tree that ends by putting these
things
in the in the subtree
elements right here
can you do expression tree
type just some expression f of
yeah whatever and second argument do
um atoms the string atoms
and then slash slash tree visualization
this will happen automatically with tree
element
so nodes like that are what we're
talking about where they have nothing in
them
yeah and they're displayed wrong here
sure yeah
what's your point
i'm sorry i i have what the notion that
you're saying
of of just having a tree of a list of
subtrees and not specifying the data i'm
saying it's useful
because right fine well then what i'm
suggesting is that the way it work is
it's tree of subtree you know sub tree
one sub tree two
et cetera et cetera et cetera um
and that that's the default form right
and that if you want data then
at that node you put node data there
okay and if you want a tree that's
ending you just put the leaf information
right here
right and unless that leaf is another
tree it's a leaf
do you see what i'm saying
seems to me this makes more sense
now for pattern matching again i think
it's going to make more sense
because i'm sorry i'm i mean so
we may have trees whose content is a
tree
whose node data is a tree yes
and we use this to to express the
expressions
which whose head is isn't is not normal
right so
operator forms yeah well let's look at
that i mean let's look at that case
because i don't think that's a um
there's nothing wrong with the node data
being a tree here
the one thing that will be tricky is if
the leaf
is supposed to be a tree exactly so
promoting
data automatically to trees in the list
of
sub trees may be tricky in that sense
so that's why if the user is always
explicit in saying i want a tree here
then we can nest two trees and then we
understand
the content is i don't understand i
don't know what i'm saying
you're saying you want a tree in the
trees section
of the tree but you want it to not be
part of the main tree you want it to be
a sub-tree
not a sub-tree but a a a broken off tree
a different you know different root
system of the tree so to speak
exactly the whole yellow box contains a
whole tree
i understand the yellow box contains a
tree
i think that's a very minority case but
i understand what
what you're saying we find it every time
that we do an operator forms tree form
we always get annoyed that it's not able
to do the right thing
so that's why we want to do the right
thing here
you see what i mean yeah i see what you
mean but i mean the the
okay so the question is is a leaf
you know one possibility is that then
the leaf
okay i've got another proposal maybe
there is a wrapper tree leaf
that can be used here
well so i view a leaf as
a special case of a tree like there's
tree leaf
q which tests whether a tree is a leaf
okay look look either we have something
where we say
tree of nothing and then data and
every leaf looks like that
i think that's crazy because i think as
we walk
down a tree we want to deliver raw
data from its nodes you said i'm saying
so if i have a tree
and i sample elements 1 0 1
one zero i do not want to get a tree out
i will if that's the leaf i want to just
get an expression out
am i making sense yes but so
what we were planning here is always to
be specific and say give me the data
so for example the tree for a tree for a
leaf could have
none in the first argument and then we
immediately see that this is a
terminal thing
well i mean this is a more convenient
version right because
this would have lied correctly instead
of having to have this null here
where the whole damn tree is full of
nulls
right now is the data not the list
two different things right okay i'm i'm
talking about
okay here's the the issue i'm addressing
i'm claiming
that the argument order is wrong i'm
coming making two claims
number one the argument order is wrong
the subtrees should come first
okay and number two the second issue is
when a tree is at the last level
can it have the payload directly in
there
or does it have so so here are
possibilities right
the payload is directly in the the tree
when it
is ending so to speak right so case one
is it can go leaf you know
leaf and then tree means it's it's more
tree
you see what i'm saying it's not a
payload right right
okay and then conceivably we could have
something which says
something like i don't know exactly what
it should be for the rare case in which
you want a tree
as the actual leaf content
you put something like that there
i think all you would need to do is put
tree there instead of verbatim
tree of tree yep i was thinking about
tree of tree why is
why is that right oh i see it so the
rule is if it's a tree trust me
i want a tree otherwise implicitly wrap
a tree around it
so right notice that that structure is
different from the usual structure
because that's not
tree of a list tree that's just
a tree of a of a pure tree right of
something which
because normally the first element here
will be a list or an association if it's
named
ports
if so you're saying normally under the
assumption that we switch the order of
arguments right
so we have the children the first i'm
saying children first yes
so that tree of tree would have to be
like
tree of like none comma tree
no no no no well okay yes right now tree
of
like tree with tree element with one
argument is just like you're saying
for children okay so it's this yes it's
this
and which is not the worst thing in the
world what's that
yeah and we could have tree of tree just
be equivalent to that
yes yes we could okay question
i mean the um what is a tree of no
children is it the same as a leaf
or not i don't think it's the same as a
leaf
i think that this is instead of a tree
of none
comet tree the glass three is not a leaf
i'm sorry an empty tree is not a leaf
you're saying what is right right so so
this is not in fact a leaf
so the correct form of this would be i
would say that is a leaf that is a leaf
whose data
is a tree no no danny is right a tree
with no children
is not a leaf that's a definition of a
leaf
oh i bet it's not a good idea where is
that a definition of a leaf
it is a live stream
wait a sec you're talking two different
but related
things an empty tree is not a leaf
a node with no children is a tree
is a leaf
may i make a suggestion i think i mean
for now
for safety we can just say none as the
first argument
means this is representing a leaf
right because the first argument
otherwise has to be a list or an
association
right right so okay so i'm going to
argue
that this is the right way around
because this way
for most of the content of a tree like
expression trees
well depends on how we're representing
heads the heads might be the node data
or they might not depending on how we're
representing it
and then so the tree
is then a tree is a list of sub trees
and if it is a purely abstract tree
without any content at the nodes then
that's all it is right
and it's just one argument it's just one
argument tree of its sub trees
if on the other hand it is uh so
so there are two forms of tagging right
so tagging
one is tagging of nodes
and that is achieved by saying tree of
subtrees
common node tag right or no node payload
right and the second case is
tagging of edges
and that's achieved by saying tree of
association
you know a goes to um
whatever it's going to sub tree blah
blah blah
blah
makes sense
okay good let's move on
okay needed at this point i'm double
booked for a function repository review
uh i don't think you're strictly needed
here to my knowledge
but the other guys who actually set this
up
i think you can leave okay thanks if
there's a question send me email or
something chat thanks thank you
okay let's continue here okay
next yeah let me ask a question
how will the annotations framework work
on trees
that's exactly the next point okay
oh okay if i remember correctly
the previous time we discussed this was
more or less the same time at work
at which the new annotation framework
was being discussed
so we were always waiting for that
but um i i don't know the answer i don't
know how to relate them
okay
so i mean i'm still not totally happy
with the annotations framework i find it
a little bit hard to understand
um okay so what's the issue here the
question is if i want to color a tree
node
red what do i do
right and if you have a node red and the
parent is blue
what's the color of the note
right um
right well that's the question of
inheritance down the tree
right which is new here it does an
existing graph
indeed in a sense dataset has a similar
issue also
of coloring all rows from here for
levels from here things like that
what do we do in dataset i think it's
not decided yet either
at the moment you can specify from
outside things like all comma one
but you have to specify specifically the
rows the boxes
okay i mean there's no way of saying
inherit from all the previous levels
from something in the previous levels
but we have the notion of inherited
um yes in cells
yes so cells probably is a good model
for this
you mean the the formatting mechanism
for cells
yes in your books
how does that work i mean in that case
okay we have option inheritance
so there we have the notion of a default
you know we can have default
is you know vertex colors
arrow inherited could be the default
right or automatic could be the default
automatic means i'm i'm
operating on my own so to speak
personally i think automatic is a better
default than inherited
for most options but maybe some options
won't have inherited
now i mean what i would favor okay so
let's talk about annotations
you know i am so confused by how
annotations work in graphs
remind me how annotations work in graphs
i think the key point is that in graph
you refer to notes by their
content well here we will refer to nodes
by the positions
and so we can still do annotate of three
position goes to value
because we could have several nodes with
the same payload so
we don't yeah okay but i mean the the
okay so it's basically position goes to
value but what what good does that do us
i see that the main point of that is you
don't have to go in and reset
something right we automatically will go
to the correct place
and put the value you want there
i mean the value will have to be a rule
itself of the option you want to modify
sure but it seems to me that the
following should work
uh you know if i say tree
oh boy okay so look look if i've got a
a pure payload i'll just say style of
payload
you know red okay on the other hand if i
want
the tree element
i see then i have subtrees here and then
i would say vertex
colors are a red and whatever the
default
indication of a node is the little
circle or whatever
that will be the thing right and and
here i might say
vertex size arrow whatever
vertex shape you know
vertex labels even arrow whatever i
could label that node
independent of it being
i'm not sure how that should be how the
labeling should work
labeling is separate from the payload
you see what i'm saying yes
um so principle this
this would only affect that node
and only if the subtrees have inherited
exactly in other words there's no way of
forcing yourself
i mean this is the this is the the only
way of forcing yourself on things is to
use annotate with a pattern
i see right so
this should then work annotate
tree you know one one zero
triple blank arrow blah blah blah
see what i'm saying right
that seems like a perfectly reasonable
way to do it that's spraying stuff
into that subtree now okay an
interesting question if you then modify
that sub-tree
does it you know how does that work what
does that actually do
does that spray at that point specific
options into the sub-tree or does it
spray inheritance into the sub-tree
interesting i don't know well i mean
actually one way to do it would be just
to do this
what you're spraying in there is vertex
colors
arrow inherited
right
i see so then we would use double blank
and a separate red for the root note
i suppose so yes yes that's right i see
this doesn't seem crazy
okay let's move on
nick is asking here whether he is
correct about um
uh
actually that two points nick is making
here okay first point he's making
is is it true that tree q is match q of
tree
um well i mean these are these can be
triple blanks and things like that
that doesn't need to be that that's an
optional thing
i think so there is a thing we were
discussing before
of having at the very bottom something
in that list that doesn't have an
explicit tree head
exactly which is what we want to do
that's what we decided we're doing
because
we're we're allowing if you want a a
tree within a tree
you're doing it with this mechanism
right
right but i mean i still think that in
input we would allow that
in output we put the head so that things
like this work it feels more
systematic probably yes probably yes
but what does the leaf look like
i'm skeptical i think the other way is
about a canonical form but we can try it
we can try that
i thought you said you wanted the
subtrees first
and then the data yes so then that would
be tree of none comma
data yes that's right yeah i think
that's what jose just said
or not yes okay
so nick is pointing out that
more consistent with graph would be
annotate
the list tree comma position
and then oh yeah this but this is right
actually
g com position and then the vertex
colors arrow whatever
right that's that's the better thing to
do yeah
yeah that's correct okay
okay all right onward
use of association
right so this is something also that is
slightly different from the old design
so in the old design
the payload itself was always an
association
in which a key was what we called
name at that point which is not payload
or data
but i think this is potentially
confusing with yeah i think
i don't see a reason to do that yeah
yeah it's better to have everything in
options now
and then children association yes yeah
which
that's fine they can be a ch they can be
an association
i don't see a problem with this there's
a technical implementation thing but we
will we will figure out
now before we move on there is something
that we were
a bit worried about in the same way that
in in both in graphing and entries the
data can have a different label
we were wondering whether the edges
could also have different labels for
example if we put associations
as base for the edges we cannot have two
edges with the same label
would that be needed i understand the
issue
well one thing is
what it is and the other thing is what
it's labeled
right exactly and in trees we come fully
separated
yeah the only issue is that these are
tree elements
designators
yeah the difficulty is
we get to say anything we want about um
the uh um
you know the nodes we get to annotate
the nodes but we don't get to annotate
the edges the only way we get to
annotate the edges
is in the association
but in a sense it each edge points to a
node
so we could store in the node the
information about
its edge oh i see what you're saying
yeah that makes perfect
sense yes that makes perfect sense
but what if there are wait a minute if
there are
two edges pointing to the same node
that cannot happen in our trees
hold on let me think about this for a
second am i totally confused
is that obvious that that oh yeah
because because you're right because
it's a literal
unrolled tree it's not like a graph
exactly yes
i've spent too much time looking at
multi-way systems where that can happen
right which are not trees turns out
the concept of tree is more general so
technically we are using something
called
oriented ordered rooted tree
so it's not the fully general tree
concept
well i think the more general tree
concept is a graph basically
yes sure but yeah
yeah okay
um okay this is an example in which we
may
want to refer with part specs using
monday but the label actually want to
show it
and something else yeah that's fine
seems fine to me okay
okay we already talked about this tree
extract
yes so this is also another thing that
we changed slightly
so in the past in the previous design
there was
there were two arguments to refer to the
path through the tree
and then the path inside the data yeah
well now because we can have nested
trees
as we discussed before for operator
forms
we want to have a single path
specification
and so we use the keyword data to
separate the moment in which you jump
from the tree to its
data and then continue to off
okay let me understand this okay so
what you're saying is if i um
you know if i get down to
a particular leaf
no wait wait a minute oh you're saying
you're saying jumping to the
to the payload of a node exactly
right and that's something we don't have
okay so
so far we have two ways of accessing
different sort of types of parts of
expressions
well actually we have three ways so in
currently we have positive indices you
know two three five et cetera et cetera
we have the somewhat weird zero for the
head
and we have key for going into an
association
for referencing a piece of an
association so what you're proposing is
another thing which
jumps to the data piece of a
tree right this is very specific for
trees
but it allows a single continuous thing
well let's let's be realistic i mean the
the thing of annotating an expression we
may very well want at some point in the
future
expressions to be annotated by like the
abstract syntax tree
for you know in the package system for
example in the new package system will
probably be one of these trees
and so this will be a general annotator
for a node of an expression
right i'm not thrilled about the fact
that that isn't a symbol
that's an idea yeah we could use a
symbol because it's something so
specific and important well but also
my question is is the correct way to do
this to have you know parts two three
four
and then have something which says you
know
inside or something it's not the right
term
blah blah blah blah blah
you know
you know whatever it is payload key
payload
something in other words rather than
just continuing
in that sub list in that list right
to indicate you're going into you're
going into something else
which then has its own i don't know if
this is a good idea
i don't know if it's good so i think
that what it's doing with data
is analogous to what it's doing with two
one and three
sure it's it's but it it is accessing
another
pocket just like key is accessing
another pocket
right the 213 thing is just saying you
know
walk down you know
you know walk down the parts here right
but what you're saying is we've already
got this notion of another pocket
right a different kind of pocket in this
case is the pockets that are indexed by
a and b
right and we've also got the pocket that
says
index the zero element there i mean
that's a very
that was a very primitive you know
different kind of pocket
in a sense two three and four are like
specifications in the list of
children so yes so
and zero is more like the specification
of the head
right but we don't want to use zero i
think you know we don't want to use a
raw zero
zero will be the closest to the thing
that we have here on the
on the particular tree element
except i don't like using zero um
also with expressions the zero is
and you know it's zero indexed of the
sub expressions at level one whereas if
we used zero for data
then it's it's kind of
it's not counting the children like one
two and three are
trees are doing this nor is this
what we're talking about is jumping to
the payload
of a node right rather than its children
right so the question is and normally
the payload of a node if i say f
x y z or f of x y in some sense f is the
payload of that node
right i mean if i say expression graph
of this
right what the heck what do i want to do
here
expression tree do i have that yep
yes and then tree visualization
okay rather i'm beautiful but but this
is but this is exactly that
you know this is working exactly that
way f is the payload of that node
you see what i'm saying yes
so what i'm saying is do level of f x y
comma list one
so i'm making the argument so zero is
like indexing this list
starting at zero whereas trees doesn't
have
something like that it's not like you
start data
yeah so what that's just the print form
of this
i mean that's why we called it element
zero
yes but this is important that that's
why expression three has a second
argument to specify what you want so
what's the other string um again
okay so i'm making the argument that it
should be zero
look i'm making the argument this should
be zero instead of data
it should just be zero
so part part zero of a tree is its data
that's what you say that's what i'm
thinking
i don't know if it's part zero and i
don't know how this relates to part
extraction
you see what i'm saying i mean this
isn't part extraction this is a tree
extract
which is a different function from apart
from from just standard part extraction
although standard part extraction should
work
right so that's why we want something
that can be as
close as possible to part specs and
position specs
i understand which is why you're trying
to avoid zero although zero seems like
it is the closest thing
it seems very close yes indeed but um
it would be nice if zero could be
maintained to replace i agree
i agree i agree i agree okay so what is
this thing
is there any name that we have the nuns
or anything like that
or automatics
i mean your idea of symbol of symbol
three
something three data three
i like that yeah but but well i mean
what about
inherited isn't quite right
um what are some other things like that
that are already existing names
full as another one
that isn't quite right either
all right so we need a name for that i
don't know what it is
it's close to being zero but it isn't
zero
[Music]
um
i mean another name which we don't use
anywhere else is content
none of these i like very much it should
be something very generic
so because three extract will extract
trees we were planning on having a tree
data function that extracts the data
so perhaps you can put the three data
because this will just be a symbol it it
somehow
somehow represents the function acting a
bit like dataset does
maybe i'm not convinced let's keep going
um
nick is commenting nice to have the
ability to get position referencing both
structure and data
eg to get the position of node aaa
anywhere in such and such a tree
okay wait a minute
let's see this is what nick is talking
about
a tree
i don't get this is this supposed to be
tree cases and you're looking for
subtrees
and doing a pattern replacement yeah
well i think this is tree cases not tree
position
i'm not quite sure i understand this
because this looks like it's spanning
two trees
oh i see i see i see this is a sibling
tree
this is matching this tree but it has a
sibling this tree here
i think this is the brackets of the
wrong way around here yeah there we go
so that matches a tree with no payload
with two children
and replaces it with the first child
yeah that looks okay i think we'll be
able to do that
okay let's keep going here
uh do i need to look at these
this is a collection of mine or other
things if you're interested
and then this is a in the section of
about changes we have added
now many things so okay he wants the
position of a sub tree for a match
oh i see i see i see
i see the issue is and you're saying
also for position
that instead of saying in position of
exper
some random
you want to know in this
let's say we've got x blank
y blank of of of zero or something here
you want to know the position of the
zero
in here when the outer matching is of
this form
do you see what i'm saying i think so
but
but position cannot do that right now no
i know i mean this case would be more
extreme
that's an interesting idea we should add
that to an ilg agenda and talk about
that in context of position
right this has appeared other times the
fact that cases takes
these rules in the second argument but
position cannot
what the heck would position do with
rules
we don't know but but perhaps it can be
used in this say
in this way right i think that's what
nick is suggesting
right yeah yeah so that's why i
mentioned it let's bring that up as an
isle the gender item
okay okay let's move on here
right
so yeah so this is all about
visualization there is these
these are the last uh
things we got from design 2018 prototype
blah well it's nicer than this
but i i mean i could lose the the brown
i think we went
we unbrowned
our graphs but i like the
the rounded corners here i like
you know i like the the lighter color of
the of the borders
and in terms of these you know default
node
i think this isn't a bad idea
and then this is a default leaf
empty leaf yeah right
seems reasonable to me i mean i think
this needs a bit of modernization but
otherwise seems
seems good so what about the idea of
distinguishing the leaves
with some different corners from the
other internal nodes
possible i'm not sure it's useful but i
think this it's something we have
discussed yeah possibly
i i think it's um we need
people from design here to discuss this
in detail but this looks like a good
reasonable direction to go in
i would what i would do is i would
slightly darken the border of the leaf
okay to begin with i see something quite
subtle
because it depends on the meaning of the
thing you know sometimes you won't want
it
it's just like you know the ultra hack
that we've been you know that's a
one-third of a century hack
is you know is this hack where you don't
show the double quotes
right you really don't show them
and that that hack has been very useful
and i think
you know in some of these things it's
like well look if you want borders here
then put borders on here
make sense
you know i can imagine at the top level
of a tree
wanting to say something like
um
um
something like this to just say
i want to do this for all my i mean how
would i otherwise do that
if i want to just do that for all leaves
in the tree
you know what i think we want this we
want leaf style and we want something
something like node style
because that way and that says that's
exactly doing this thing about
that's saying down the tree i want this
to work all the way down
it can be overridden by a specific thing
but if you say leaf style arrow red or
something
that just makes all the leaves red
i think we want something like this
okay should we go on here
what about something like inherited
style which is able to
you but i think it's convenient to just
say
okay i've got this tree everything in
the sub tree i want the leaves to be
this way everything in the subject i
want the nodes to be this way
i understand the idea what i'm worried
about is the
is it tailoring towards leaves and notes
only what about if i want something in a
branch
yeah i understand the edges right
exactly so well that's easy enough
because you just told me how to do that
because the node style right is
that's just telling me i mean okay i
admit that the leaves it doesn't handle
but that's in fact in fact your your
scheme that has an edge style
does that handle oh yeah yeah right
right right right right right
the node style is a downward
the edge style
of a given node
wait a minute it's the incoming edge
for a tree right that is the edge style
okay so in this case the ink how would
you label
how would you color you know how would
you make a dotted line
for the incoming edge of a leaf
the same thing we just said but how
would you do it
because aisle goes to something of what
edge style of what because remember the
leaf
ash know what it is what's that no no
look
look look look look the leaf
is just a raw leaf here
right so how do you wrap an edge style
on that leaf
essentially it doesn't look like a leaf
that looks like a tree with multiple
children
no no no that's a leaf that's what we
agreed
that unless you wrap another tree there
any
expression other than a tree
is a literal leaf right
so what i'm asking is if you want an
edge style coming into that leaf how do
you do it
tree of leaf comma edge style
all right fine fine
but then there's an argument
okay
i'm not sure then about this but i mean
this particular thing this idea
yeah your idea that every node
it may be convenient to have a way of of
referencing the leaves separately
um so this you're saying really should
be tree
of
something like that which would give the
inherited style for everything
maybe actually we could even call it
tree style
because it is the style of the whole
tree
as opposed to just that node
right
see i think this is not completely
stupid
okay so let's keep going here
okay
okay i don't understand yet the heads
goes to true stuff here
okay yeah so sure that note was just
more about your instruction that tree
form should
be consistent with this visualization
yes
well that's for sure tree structure
yes we need that
something like tree structure form i
don't know if that's the right term
okay what are we looking at here is this
is this
old i don't understand what this is all
about
this is our new notes of design we are
not looking at comparison anymore
okay okay fine so what we are wondering
here is the various ways of visualizing
a tree that we will need
i don't know whether this is the right
name for this this underlying form
[Music]
um
and what would that do it would use the
the node labels as the labels of
the underlines that correct
i think that's correct yeah
okay
okay well yes i think this tree outline
i mean
i i personally prefer tree brows if it's
an interactive thing
i think
possibly tree outline but i i think tree
browser is better because the tree
outline it's not clear it's a verb
make sense okay
tree highlight
i think not because i think it's just
annotate of a particular
you know the reason we need graph
highlight is because it's highlighting
well it might be useful because it's
it's like a
a bank specified annotation so to speak
it's it's like if we say tree highlight
and then we list three things to
highlight it will automatically pick
three different colors et cetera et
cetera et cetera
right for large objects this is
this could be quite useful right
okay well anyway i think that's a you
know that's more on the luxury
items department and we've got plenty of
stuff to do before that that's
effectively an annotate
with appropriate options right indeed
okay what's the issue here so if i say
dendrogram
of range of 10
it's a very uninteresting dendrogram um
i mean let's do
dendrogram of random real
10 10. okay there we go
so what's the question here
so this is a tree that doesn't have data
at the payloads
it only has it at the leaves so yeah
well great
if you had a tree that did have data in
its payloads
would you still want to have a
dendrogram
plot or something like that yes and
yeah that's just one of the stars of
tree visualization
um i don't know whether this is look the
fact that these things are drawn squared
off like this
i don't think is particularly dendrogram
specific
i don't think i think that's just a
style of tree visualization
i see i i don't know what the
significance of the height of this
of this um thing is i think that's
that's giving us an indication of the um
uh some kind of closeness measure or
something
i don't really know what that is but a
squared off tree like this absolutely
we absolutely need this
uh i mean this is just one of the styles
like
yeah i mean we should have had this in
graph visualization tree plot should
have this
right okay
tree plots should work with trees i mean
as it works with graphs
okay tree element patterns
okay what on earth is this now
oh boy sparse array is the first
argument to tree is an interesting one
which surely should be supported it's
not very difficult to support
well
the point here is that we were planning
to have three elements with patterns
inside
or rules three because patterns inside
and construct a tree whose payloads are
patterns
while sparse array will understand
as a construction mechanism
rather than constructing as parts array
whose content
are patterns yeah what is the objective
here all together
well in this section we explain that we
need to be able to do pattern matching
with trees i think we
agree the main question would be whether
we need a tree
or not or we can leave with tree itself
okay so what are we patternizing in the
tree
the whole tree the whole subtree oh well
that's fine that's just part of the
first argument
because the first argument is a tree is
a list of sub-trees and they can be
patternized
what's the issue
so imagine that you want to construct
one of those trees with patterns using
rules three
okay and then rules three with patterns
which is in second line
i think should return a three element or
three
containing patterns
yeah it could but but i mean there's a
different issue
which is
okay here's the thing i might want to do
i've got a tree
and i want everything whose tree
yeah here's an extreme case right i want
something like this
all elements whose trees designation is
that this is a replace part type
operation
something like that or give me all
elements
whose i mean presumably tree cases
no how would i do that this is this is a
form of tree extract if i want all
tree pieces all sub trees
whose paths to get to them are like that
yes so i think that's just tree extract
if i'm not mistaken
but the extract doesn't take patterns
well maybe it should
i mean okay this is clearly useful
because to get this as a ordinary
pattern
i've got to go and have this rodentified
pattern of tree of tree of tree of tree
of tree
right which is a big nuisance
see what i'm saying
yes this question is not
related to trees it's also in general
whether
extract should take patterns and
what does extract extract returns
directly the expression not a list of
expressions right so
i don't think it could really you know
maybe there's an extract
list no it does extract the list of
expressions
if you have a list of position specs it
will return a list of
expressions i know but this isn't a list
of position specs it's a pattern
which is like if if you give it look if
i say
it's just gonna give me a literal piece
but if you put the list of list one two
it will
give you sure absolutely but but it
seems wrong that
this will suddenly give me a list out
i i think i know how to do it so take
your expression in the first argument
the extract of the first the first
argument in extract and do position
of that comma blank
so now that that's all the list of all
positions now now we have to pattern
match this and extract the cases that
match your pattern
exactly yeah no i agree with the
semantics
i'm objecting to the fact that i think
extract is the wrong thing to do that
because i i'm concerned about the fact
that extract
well maybe it's okay i mean that if it
if it's given a pattern it will always
return a list if it's given
a non-pattern it will typically try to
return a single element
all right to me
right which is why i'm proposing more
something like extract list which will
be the analogue replaced list
that will say extract in all possible
ways
so for example if i said here well if i
just said blank here
right if i say extract blah blank
right then it should give me well i
don't know whether blank what blank
should do but i think
more you know if i say blank blank blank
like that
then it should give me the complete list
of all parts
right then that will be equivalent of
level
this thing comma zero comma infinity
i think that's a useful function and for
trees it's going to be more useful
honestly that function would also be
useful for things like data sets
because that would give me like if i
want
well really does it
what's the difference between extract
list
and comma all actually you know i'm
about to blow up my own argument
because look at this
oh all only works in the first argument
right all comma one why doesn't it work
on the second argument
it's a limitation extract but is that
but okay but that's blowing up my
argument that it always returns a single
element
when it's a form like that what do you
mean it's a limitation of extraction
it's just a bug or is it is it um no
when all was added to extract it was
added this way
you can't have any number of holes at
the beginning but always at the
beginning
but it doesn't need to be that way
there's nothing semantically blocking it
from
from going from doing the other case
right
well ragged cases might get tricky
okay separate separate discussion
okay let's continue here
i think just one more thing this links
with something we have discussed other
times which is
uh symbolic position specs something
that represents like a diagonal or
yes so it's something that a single
thing returns a list
or represents a list of fair enough and
and as you say we've already crossed
that bridge by having the all case
hold on just one second here second
okay all right let's keep going
all right so there's still some
questions here okay empty trees
i think we discussed this i don't think
we care about this
i think we figured out what we need to
figure out with this
non-terminal nodes i think we've also
discussed this haven't we
yes okay um
i mean there's things here that we
haven't discussed in this meeting like
the fact that depth and and how negative
level specs work with that
ah okay
well tree depth
yeah i'll treat up seems straightforward
to me what's
what's complicated about tree depth so
tree depth of an internal or a non
for a yes a non-terminal
leaf would be like plus one compared to
a terminal leaf
it's as if it had another level
well the tree depth is not the depth is
that what you're saying
no this is so this is the difference
between like f and f
bracket bracket
okay in this tree here what is its depth
its tree depth is one
are these terminal nodes
those are terminal nodes right i don't
know maybe that's a maybe that's not a
terminal node but let's assume these are
all terminal nodes here
it's true depth is one i see but it's
depth depth
but so then if you changed one of the
leafs
to an to a non-terminal leaf
then the depth would increase by one
even though you didn't actually add
another level to the tree
what the heck is a non-terminal leaf i
mean so anon look
in our way of setting this up where we
say tree of
leaf comma whatever right tree of a
comma b okay no payload there
all right what is the depth of that tree
the tree depth of that is one i would
assume
or is it zero i think it's one
it's got to be one i would say that
would be one okay
all right great okay so now if one of
these
is a tree
even if it has so now say none comma a
okay okay so say empty list comma a
yeah what's the tree depth of that i
think it's probably two that would be
two
i'm fine with that right even though
right tree of empty list comma a
would be an a non-terminal leaf
okay let me let me make a comment about
this make a comment i think
this should be indicated visually in
some way
this is a vestigial tree this isn't the
same as just b
here right so you you designed terminal
and non-terminal leaves already
i'm so non-terminal leaves would
render exactly the same as like a
regular
sub tree in the middle of the tree okay
okay
whole leaves would be the things that
great then i don't see any problem with
this tree depth interpretation
okay and so you're also okay with level
negative one would be just the terminal
leaves
and then non-terminal leaves would be
level negative two
yeah level minus one is the term on the
leaves yes is it so level minus one of
this tree
so in particular like tree depth and and
tree level don't need like a leaf type
option
it's fine for them to you know
okay so i claim that this should be
a b yep
if you did tree level of negative you
know negative one of the tree right
above
then you would only get b that's correct
okay perfect seems right to me
um
okay
um
nick is commenting on various things
about position
pattern
i think these seem like great neck
function repository suggestions
well okay so this is a wrapper
that's interesting
that's basically a thing to put into a
part extractor
that represents a patterned
part
yeah well and there's an example here
of position cases
yeah right it's this kind of thing
i agree that these things could
perfectly well work
okay anyway let's let's move on because
it's not subject here
tree depth we just talked about
a ray depth versus array is that a sub
case of this
what the heck does what does a ray death
have to do so this is what we discussed
tree depth of tree list a b
is that one or is that um okay so we
just handled this
exactly okay you haven't seen
so you specify a pattern in the second
argument and then it gives you the
level that it finds that pattern
okay i wonder why depth doesn't do that
because it's a version one function that
hasn't been touched
oh my god look at that look at all those
updates
why is there a a
um a bullet thing there
and a vertical bar here can we find that
out oh because these are all updates
yeah okay okay well i didn't know it had
been had so much
uh care
exercised on it fair enough
perhaps to update it for new structures
oh that's most likely right
yeah okay
all right what's next tree graph
now use the data
as the vertices rather than unique
integers
i see so uses the data from
the vertices in the graph as the payload
in the tree
so this is going from tree and producing
a graph
oh so what is it doing
using data as vertices rather than
unique integers
can i see this work yeah so open
ref tree graph extension
and these examples should work
yeah the problem here is that if you
have several nodes with the same payload
the graph is not going to reproduce the
tree and there's an example of that
lower
so hold on a second this is right now i
have to say tree visualization of this
yes by the way i mean this default size
is all wrong you do know that right
yeah i'm pretty sure everything about
this is wrong okay but but in general
because these things have textual data
here you should be
you know that thing should be scrunched
up about that size
right and if you need to
i'll i mean you know in other words i
think that the
average distance between these sort of
lines of
lines of tree if you understand what i'm
saying
should burn the order of twice the
height of the nodes
maybe see what i'm saying
yep um
okay so now what's the question here so
this is tree visualization so now
if i say a tree graph of this
sorry you complicated it's a it's a
there's a private symbol
you get to copy off of the ref page for
now
for which tree golf yep
uh that wasn't very helpful oh because i
wrapped entry visualization
okay so this is the graph and if i save
that graph
vertex labels to automatic
dandasaurus but now if i were to go back
here
if i were to go here and i would say i
can guess what's going to happen here
and i would say d goes to a
i'm going to have a weird graph right
okay
well we got a problem there
so what we were what we were planning is
to have a function that
intercepts the payloads with the
position and create something new
you can say still keep the only the data
or merge it with the position in some
way
yeah i mean a little bit like index for
nearest and things like this exactly
i think this is going to cause
horrendous bugs this this
lack of um
well it might have decided the default
we could say that by default we
place pairs payload composition
no i understand that i understand it but
i'm asking the question if you want it
to round trip is there a way to do that
by having
the graph distinguish its nodes in some
way that is
removable when you go back to the tree
i see i mean we could have a convention
that graph tree
strips out certain kinds of things
associated with it for example let's say
that it was of the form index arrow
payload
okay we could remove
the you know index
part of that when we go to the tree
or just use it to actually make the
indices in the tree
in other words and then if a graph
doesn't have
its node names being rules like that
then we joke just right ahead and make a
tree if we can we might not be able to
make a tree
you see what i'm saying you should
always be able to make
so the other direction i think has no
problems like graph tree
you already have a graph where the
vertices are all distinct
by virtue of it being tree graphq
no you mean tree graph making a
graph making contributions
how can you make a tree from a graph no
nonsense
what if my graph is is a you know it's
just a cycle
i can't make it right right it has to be
tree graph q that's what it is okay
fine you have a tree graphq graph you
do graph tree and you get a tree and
then you do
tree graph you'll get back the original
graph
well you will right now yes same
vertices yeah
right exactly what i'm saying is
if you go from a tree to a graph
to put in annotations at the nodes of
the graph
that have the form tree indices
goes to payload okay
that that's the default and
then on the way back we say by default
any graph whose node names are blah
arrow blah
you know get stripped now we have to
parametrize this because it might go
wrong
uh but i think that's the that's
the basic idea so that we can round trip
make sense yes
i have this bad feeling we might regret
this but i think it's okay
um i tori on the livestream is asking
about
uh can this be used to visualize
decision trees from classified we
certainly hope so
it is one of the intended use cases have
you talked to the machine learning
people about that
ian no i
i brought this up with jesse okay i bet
i need to connect
uh okay please do because jesse didn't
know that this project was happening
with trees and he's in the process of
making
trees um
right it should give a directed graph by
default if you don't want to direct your
graph say undirected graph of the thing
in my view do you agree
yes okay i i agree
okay tree extra
boy okay
so we discussed last week that we wanted
to eliminate the symbol
and keep lists yeah i think that's
correct
we i mean it's going to lead to some
small ambiguities if we just have to
analyze
how problematic they are okay
but now genealogical position specs
i think this is something that will be
very useful with trees
refer being able to refer to all
grandchildren
and things like that yeah i agree
one issue with grandchildren is your a
grandchild is like a double blank
you know not a grand no that's that's a
grand
star child so to speak
band to the end child um
but what i mean is a grandparent
represents two
uh you know two elements in the tree
path
but so what's the idea here the idea is
that we would have um
strings what the heck's gonna happen if
we're
referencing associations inside here
right so associations would require key
that's annoying or or at least i have a
different suggestion
i have a different suggestion i have a
different suggestion it's a pun
tree relative that's the wrapper for
each of these things
so in other words if you want uh
you know you're going down one two three
you know cousin first cousin whatever
tree relative
cousin you see what i'm saying
so it's a it's going in this direction
of symbolic parts
i see
i'm concerned about the following case
okay
tree relative parent right that is that
element there isn't it
yes yes it's undoing the last one yeah
right
which is fine you may have had children
and then comma parent and then that
would be the parent
i mean you know what i mean cousins you
could have
something other than just an index there
i like the term true relative i think
that's a very amusing
pun so saying it's both relative to the
tree
and it's a relative in the same sense
that
you know what i'm talking about yeah
there
um i can imagine tree relative
actually being a thing that we use in
general part specifications
let me look at what some of these are
here
oh my god some of these are horrendous
and something important here is that
some of them are plurals
and so they are like all they will
return a list of parts
wait a minute how can you be wait a
minute what if i say aunts instead of
uncles
okay let's okay hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on
human genealogical trees are not trees
is that a true statement
yes in full generality they're a
dag
a dag where every vertex has it's a big
okay so hold on the
okay but but in genealogy right there's
this notion of an
hourglass diagram right where there's
you in the middle
then your children are below and then
your parents are above
right and then
you have two parents
i'm so confused so because we have
so these are rooted trees so we would
not have the hourglass we would just
have like the lower half of the
hourglass
right but what if i want my ancestors
what if i wanted three of my ancestors
it's a reverted tree so i think that
part is easy you just use two trees
one for the past one for the future so
but
that's not right because if if you know
you're
you know like
you know if you marry your first cousin
and you have you know in like the darwin
you need to grab in general
to represent family relationships
you would need a directed acyclic graph
where every vertex has two parent nodes
and you get a tree from that by
arbitrarily selecting one parent node
for each vertex that you're interested
in
and there you obtain a tree and because
of
you know the fact that every two humans
is technically some form of cousin to
every other
human that will not be unique it'll
depend on the choice of which parent
you choose to represent the family tree
as a tree
i see well and and you know we're no
doubt cousins in 18 different ways so to
speak
exactly the um
okay so is there a generic okay wait a
minute
for an uncle right what is an uncle in
this tree
so if i'm here right this is my parent
and this here is the sibling of my
parent right
yep so that's the uncle of this
no yep is that correct b is the
data at the uncle of e yep
okay
it's a pity there isn't a a
gender-neutral
aunt uncle term is there there is for
nieces and nephews
what is it nibblings oh that's
ridiculous i've never heard that
is that new or is that has that been
around did you find that
we were worried about that and we were
looking for the existing ones and
apparently
nibblings is something that is getting
accepted is relatively new
but the other case is there is no
agreement at all
i see nibblings as in like siblings yes
yeah because i mean cousin obviously
isn't gen in english at least is not
gender
specific i don't know maybe it is in
other languages i don't know
um what is an
ascendant
is that ancestors
or descendants it's it's the inverse of
descendants
then we should call it ancestors because
that's what everybody calls it
the ancestor of a node the ascendant is
like a
you know some kind of
who knows what um
well i never heard of a nibbling that's
kind of a cool word
um is it a new word or has it been
around for a hundred years
i think it's relatively new let me try
to find again
the okay
but so you're okay what about a great
great
uncle for example or now if we have tree
relative
we could imagine having
a i mean because okay look look it gets
you know involved in alpha
okay let's do the following thing
immoral from alpha we do have the
concept of a you know first cousin three
times removed
that kind of thing right the concept of
cousins removed is a thing in trees
isn't it that's not something specific
to genealogical trees
about the relative difference in level
compared to your
least common ancestor
i see the the the cousin the second
cousin
is the common ancestor is a grandparent
is it
and then the removal is how you know
what's the difference
at the levels of the two
okay so fine so what we're going to need
and this is this is a separate thing and
it will be packed inside tree relative
will be a way of doing control equals
third cousin once removed
and turning that into some symbolic
representation the geological
representation of the genealogical
thing now now there is a standard thing
i think in used in genealogy programs
that represents those you know it's a
standard
rather rather packed numerical
vector form of these these kinds of
relations
right it's basically saying how many do
you go back
i think it's it's what you're saying how
far
okay so by the way
you know bizarrely the same thing has
come up in our
um physics project this is the this is
um
uh in branchial graphs this is you know
how many
it's a common ancestry graph i wrote
some definitions out in bullet points
in the agenda
uh well under genealogical position
specs
not seeing it up up
right there oh yeah yes
children is fine subtrees and
descendants are fine parent is fine
ah boy
so nobody talks about negative first and
zeroth cousins because
those are immediate family and they have
different
words like i know but we we there's no
reason why we can't do that
um and then the other thing is like
niece and nephew
that what is the minus second cousin
minor second cousin minus second minus
two
cousin i don't think there is one
that doesn't exist because that's a
forward relation your negative first
cousin zero times removed is yourself
right
okay right your first cousin your zeroth
cousin is your siblings
is that correct siblings and the nieces
nephews aunts uncles grand nieces
etc no no your zeroth cousin
zero cousin zero times removed his
cousins
removed his siblings sorry
right but the default number of times
removed
is by default an nth cousin is end times
the default right
no but it's zero times removed as in
it's at the same level genealogical tree
exactly right
okay and there's just saying what the
common ancestor is so this is the
this is the uh i don't know i think
we're calling it branchial depth
in the physics project
and the other point is that like words
like nieces and nephew
those specify who is older or who's at
the higher level
but in general like second cousin three
times removed does not specify
which one is closer to the common
ancestor
but you can i'm sorry i'm sorry say that
again so customarily
when you say second like say second
cousin three times removed
you don't know who is closer to the
common ancestor
it's a symmetric binary relation whereas
for immediate family if you say nice
you know niece is not the same thing as
ant but they're the same type of
cousin
okay so this is the second cousin three
times removed
that's the graph and if you labeled the
one on the right
self and labeled the one on the left as
second cousin three times removed
that would also be accurate
because it's a symmetric relation so
i see removal is is an absolute value
a removal quantity is an absolute value
so you don't know if i say
somebody is twice removed you don't know
if they're much older or much younger
than
me whereas for immediate family that i
bet that's different in different
languages anybody know for any other
languages
so in spanish at least you always use
like one of these words uncle
carson nephew and then you keep saying
second third but you know it's a nephew
so it's one generation below you
women so it's essentially a vector in
the tree
it's a it's a second nephew third nephew
is that right
exactly huh
it's an interesting concept actually for
i mean our interpretation in terms of
hilbert spaces but anyway let's not
worry about that
the um
okay but here see i think there's a
notation for this isn't there
that it's just some you know collection
of numbers
that just say how far you go back to the
common ancestor
how and how many i mean this is actually
two coordinate
differences that not correct
the distance of the common ancestor and
the number of levels different that you
are
am i correct yes those are the in fact
look at this i mean this is determine
nnk for
right so that this is in fact what it's
giving difference in generations
and generations to common ancestor
so if i say and so it's giving an
absolute
difference right i understand
i mean if i say uncles uncles
parents and this is where i'm probably
parent's son
okay this is where it starts mattering
that the people have
two parents is that right
the heck is this
oh boy these are representing pairs of
parents as a
vertex oh look at this
six additional relations with no
standard names
oh boy
okay hold on
i should know this stuff my my mother
wrote her phd thesis and anthropology on
on
the theory of a bunch of these relations
for different kinds of societies
but it was before i was born so why
should i know
what's that you're the root of the tree
it's not pictured
it's a bad joke oh i didn't yeah right
um
anyway okay
maybe i should look at her she wrote a
book about such such issues at some
point
maybe i should look it because it
probably has a bunch of information
about what
i mean i assume that these these
relation names yeah i mean it'd be
interesting to know whether anybody has
a fundamentally different way of doing
this
because you know this is clearly what we
are doing here is
is is highly you know anglo-centric so
to speak
i mean maybe not i don't know i don't
know how universal this stuff is
i know that um uh
you know if you if you look at for
example the the um
you know you're allowed to marry your
first cousin your
you're i know in england for a long time
the deceased wife
sister was a big was for like
you know ages and ages and ages was a
big sort of uh
you know is that is that does that can
is that considered
an incestuous relation or not um
but and so i think that they're these
things where where you have a certain
essentially tree distance that counts as
an incestuous relation and you have a
certain
i think um the other one in in
traditional etiquette right is is uh
how long you should be in mourning if a
relation
some distance away from you on the
genealogical tree dies
um and uh so that that's another metric
on the space of these kinds of trees
there there's a piece of complete trivia
for you
um but in any case i we should at least
look up
i mean there must be there must be um uh
you know there must be information about
this how this works in other
other societies and so on where there
may be other
you know and let's see whether we can
parameterize it in some more
precise essentially mathematical way
which might just be
relations to common ancestor and levels
on the tree different
and maybe we don't care i mean i don't
know whether that has applications in i
don't know
you know analyzing xml documents or
something you know the grand
uncles of xml tags
may or may not be relevant i don't know
anybody anybody have a sense of that
i mean if we're doing genealogy we're
not going to get it right anyway because
as you say
the whole thing is really a dag because
of the relations being
more more complicated
yeah and the key important thing is that
we cannot handle two parents
so it's it's this is like monopoly
families on the way
it's like what monopole
oh mono parental families yeah well
i mean eventually we should be doing
something with genealogy where we're
actually able to do the
the um the actual case of humans so to
speak
um
okay
we discussed this before yep okay
x path yes
expression tree okay we talked about
head packing for expression trees
right i don't think we've looked at deep
in detail at the structures
and i have a question there about how
custom structures should work
what kind of custom structures
so like if the user wants to specify a
pattern
it says replace an expression of this
form with a tree of this form
how do they do that when would they do
this in an expression tree
yes i see the basic point is you don't
want to explode some piece of your
expression tree
into this very complicated tree object
you just want to pack those all into a
single node
right that's the most common case it's
like i don't want to expand these
polynomials
out into their individual you know
variables and powers and things i just
want to pack every polynomial into a
single node
or for example associations we don't
want a node for each rule
so it each special type of structure xml
text element we want to avoid
additional connectors i see it in other
words
provide a large number of built-in
structures but also
right so you're saying two things first
of all what's infrastructure
and what's data and the other
how how much do you burrow down and at
what point you just say forget it it's
the leaf
right right so those seem to be the two
issues to me
you have to pick your you know pick what
counts as a leaf
i'm i'm ignoring you know uh complex
headdresses and so
so to speak okay what what counts as a
leaf at what point you just say okay
it's a leaf i'm going to treat it as
atomic
and then what forms of
infrastructure you say i'm going to
ignore
you know this list just represents the
collection of children
rather than well that's always going to
be the case for an expression tree right
it's it's
oh i see but i see it i see it's you may
have like some
some certain kind of expression that you
want to handle differently
no but but let's be specific about that
so a list
the basic point there is you want that
to be an anonymous node
right so in other words the the what you
want to do is you want to say certain
certain things like list okay two cases
in my view
one is what counts as a okay so the the
two cases um
you know what counts as a leaf
i.e is atomic
and the second thing is um
how do i go from
a an expression with me with many
subparts
into an intermediate node
okay so for example if i have list
you know a b c d whatever the fact is
that's
that i probably want that to be an
anonymous node
i agree whereas you know if i have
f of a b c d what do i want to do or do
i want that to be
a node where the f is the payload
or what
that makes sense yeah right that's what
we're trying to control exactly right
okay do you have an idea for how to do
that or not yep open the
expression tree ref page
oh boy
okay i think i'm running out of time i
mean i'm late for another meeting here
he says looking at this huge
thing okay heads of some expressions of
the expression
i don't understand this how is it struck
just i don't understand this
i i think we should be looking at the
excluded part which is
naming the structures for which we are
going to do something special
what extrude part i mean here here it's
saying structs what does this mean
so you could have a list of structures
and if
you ran into you'd test them in order
and whichever ones match you know you
apply them in order
what do they do they need to
specify what the data for the
tree is and what its children should be
so wait a minute so this is really an
association the struct thing
which says head trees arrow some blister
patterns is that right
no head trees is like a named
rule that says how to transform an
expression into a tree
what does it mean so the
the head of the expression gets turned
into a tree and used as the data
and its children are the trees
corresponding to the arguments
i see okay so that's that's one style of
that
but you're saying something different
about when you encounter
a particular sub-expression what do you
do with it
basically basically what you need to do
is you've hit a sub-expression okay
you know you hit a sub-expression
and then what do you do so for that
sub-expression you say
extract what the
uh you know children should be
okay should the sub-expression be atomic
if yes then you're done it's a leaf yep
okay otherwise extract what the children
should be
extract what the payload should be
exactly and so these are the two
like in nesh tree you would specify this
with two functions
and originally there was this idea that
you would have left hand side arrow tree
element
but i think that that is using tree
element slightly
differently than how we've been using it
by the way kobe suggests that we define
it in terms of space-like and time-like
separation which is basically right i
mean that this is
this is i mean it's it's it's somewhat
these bronchial coordinates rather than
pure space like but
well we could do it it's like light
cones
okay never mind we're um
binary trees are like that but we have
more
yes we have more more than binary trees
right well that's the case
wait a minute
yeah right and i mean this is where you
know the the gendered children
you know it's like sister's
cousin's daughter you know
you're you've got two colorings of the
of the edges of the
you know in the in the tree rather than
just
um a bucket of nodes
okay in any case all right so you've got
various functions for this
i think we're going to have to come back
to this one but let's have a quick look
and then i should disappear
oh boy
oh there's quite a bit of stuff here
isn't there
oh so most of this hasn't been filled in
yeah
these are this is material for example i
see
okay okay
okay cool an xml do you have
oh my gosh do you have examples here
yes you do you have your tree outline
example here which i i think we need a
little bit more
on the xml thing i think you also should
get some porous trees
i think um chris cooley has some stuff
for his code structure
project that is i think he has parse
trees there
for code which are pretty complicated
does that make sense
it's the analog it's the analog of text
structure for
random c code and so on right
do you understand what i'm talking about
i haven't heard of that but yeah okay
is it chris no chris cooley in in todd's
group
and that's almost finished actually it's
about to go into the function repository
may already exist there
and it will take arbitrary random
languages like c and java and so on and
show you
abstract syntax trees and all that kind
of thing
right but i can imagine brenton also has
trees
yes brentano is also probably quite
quite tree oriented
um talking of trees if you want to find
a big pile of trees
um all that combinator stuff that i was
doing is full of trees
i don't know whether they're relevant to
this where would we use that i suppose
we could have used that
yeah i mean if you want some uh here
i'll just show you
a place to get a lot of trees and and
the functions that create this stuff are
all in function repository now
um
this is full of trees where were they
where are they
um
well these are oh by the way these are
representations of trees you can pick
these up from the function repository
these are all different renderings of
trees
which we probably should have the
functions to render them are in the
function repository
i hope so okay they're supposed to be i
mean they're recently put there so
that's not like the type setting for a
multi-way system or something
no no no no no okay so this is
unfortunately not yet
really properly set up i mean this is
right now being loaded in from a cloud
file
right but these are these are going i
thought they were already in there
in the function repository but but
anyway they're they're coming if they're
not already there
but this this is useful we should have
these
these are just different tree
visualizations right
okay um and obviously many trees here
so it'd be good to figure out how we'd
represent these trees
make sense
and notice that you know this is the
default rendering of the tree
but it's sometimes useful to just say
make it a graph layout so probably the
graph layout option of trees should be
supported
um that's a complicated thing if you can
do that
i'll be impressed that's a tree
transformation
we should think about how that would
work that's an extremely straightforward
thing
in terms of standard pattern matching
it makes sense this seems like balancing
yeah it's an interesting way to think
about it actually i mean it's picking up
a bunch of subtrees and doing things
that's the
s combinator i see
i never thought about it that way
actually
um anyway so this is just full of tree
tree stuff
this is another things perhaps of
interest these are dags made from trees
by
by finding common sub parts which might
be an operation that we would like
for some of our trees right in other
words up to find common sub expressions
in the tree
and daggify it
makes sense i'm not sure if that's
useful
but but um
anyway yeah lots and lots of trees in
here you can find
you can find one thing might be useful
to you here this is a way of generating
really huge trees
very easily i mean these trees have you
know
well there this one had whatever it was
thousand
uh that's ten of the four elements but i
have one much bigger than that
um so okay i need to go to my next thing
um this was very good this is this is
this is looking very nice i mean this is
great
uh boy it's complicated much more
complicated than i thought
uh um i think it seems like we've now
reached the the um
we now understand the depth of the
complexity is that a fair statement
but there are not things we expect as we
look at different applications we're not
expecting
all kinds of other crazy things to jump
out
no i don't think so okay and and by the
way
in terms of different shoe
visualizations menu structures clearly
the visualization for that is rather
different where it's a very horizontally
oriented
layout of the trees than these other
kinds of things
um
yeah kobe's is mentioning some things
about multi-way graphs
the first node path from that expression
yes i don't think we've thought about
this i i need to think about
multi-way graphs in a more genealogical
way um
all right on to the next thing thanks a
lot guys
thanks to folks on the livestream um
and uh until the next time